[Music]
the world's biggest democracy just had
an election the world's biggest
democratic election marathon election
kannada undertaking the world's biggest
exercise in democracy in india voters
picked its central government for the
next five years an eighth of the world's
population was eligible to vote in this
election this year 2019 there are 900
million eligible voters in India making
this the largest Democratic exercise in
the history of humanity but this isn't a
video about indian politics because
before india's people can even cast
their vote
the election needs to come to them
polling stations need to be set up
wherever people live and in one of the
largest and most populous countries in
the world that isn't an easy task
india has to reach voters in coastal
cities in the south in the rural regions
of the west and jungles to the east and
everywhere in between and what's more
they want every Indian citizen to be
within 2 kilometers of a voting station
that's only about 25 city blocks
no matter where you are in the country
and yet somehow able to do it this is
the biggest election in the world and I
wanted to know how does it work
[Music]
every election a team of government
officials and security forces get on a
boat in the east of India to take off
towards this island
they travel about a hundred kilometres
to get here all to securely deliver
these electronic voting machines or EVMS
the instrument that logs India's votes
the heart of this elaborate election
process
India has 2.3 million voting machines
for its 900 million voters so getting
these machines close to every voter is a
big logistical undertaking
that's why India doesn't have a single
Election Day
instead it's closer to an election month
with multiple phases that last weeks
this process takes more than 11 million
election officials and security forces
who moved from polling station to
polling station to polling station from
densely populated cities to the rural
areas where the majority of Indians live
once on the island with the EVMS
officials pylon 2 bike carts and head
towards the polling station
[Music]
once they arrive they begin setting
everything up for the vote now that the
vote don't nobody can I say one
important each in started your name I'm
a little coup B you shall overshadow you
look mom are both double super gotcha
punches into the party hey on Election
Day voters line up cast their vote and
get their fingers inked to prevent
double voting this is where the process
ends for the voters for the election
officials this is just the beginning
driving a boat out to a remote island is
just one of many ways that officials
reach every voter India's vast and
diverse terrain requires transportation
methods of all kinds like in the jungles
of this northern state where elephants
transport voting machines to reach a
remote town or in the Himalayas where
officials hike for hours to bring EVMS
for election day
helicopters trains they even use camels
but what makes India's elections so
impressive isn't just how they reach
everyone in such a big country that's
just half the battle it's also the ways
they tried to include voters of all
backgrounds into the process a challenge
that has been a part of India's
elections since the very beginning
India has 22 official languages and
hundreds of dialects and when India
became an independent nation less than a
quarter of the population could read and
write the newly formed Election
Commission of India created a range of
symbols to correspond to each political
party like an elephant a lotus a hand or
even an alarm clock so that from the
beginning all people regardless of
literacy level and language could vote
with confidence since 1947 the literacy
rate has increased significantly but
it's still only 75 percent so these
symbols are still useful to many when
casting a vote
but this is a massive sprawling
operation and over the years it's run
into some pretty serious problems like
allegations of election rigging and
problems with a practice called booth
capture where gangs actually take over
polling stations and tamper with the
elections it's partly because of these
problems that the Commission introduced
these voting machines in the 1990s it
also increased security around the
elections these efforts to include all
voters and protect elections seem to be
working in 2019 India saw the highest
voter turnout yet and for the first time
women voted just as much as men to carve
us in that India's elections are only
getting bigger and more complicated
India has one of the fastest growing
populations in the world and in 2020
young people will make up more than a
third of the country so happy that I did
my voting for the first time yes this is
the biggest election in the world that
takes millions of officials fanning out
across a massive country to help
hundreds of millions vote every part of
this the symbols the elephants the boats
the machines shows how hard it is to
make sure that everyone in the country
this large can participate and all
without going more than 2 kilometers
from home
if you want to learn more about the
evolution of democracy in South Asia you
should check out the Bhutan episode of
Asian monarchies a series of
documentaries on curiosity stream
curiosity stream is a subscription
streaming service that offers thousands
of documentaries and nonfiction titles
from some of the world's best filmmakers
for $2.99 a month but because you are a
borders fan you can get the first 31
days for free if you go to curiosity
stream comm slash borders and enter the
promo code borders curiosity stream is
the exclusive sponsor of this season of
borders and while they don't influence
our editorial process or what the videos
are about they support us and help make
videos like this possible so thank you
curiosity stream you should definitely
go check them out and stay tuned for
more borders